foreign
of the ocean beneath the waves the story
of a young whale's astonishing voyage
across uncharted waters is about to
begin but this is not Earth's ocean nor
is this in Earth whale this is The Saga
of South scrimshaw a Game documentary
hybrid created by the brilliant Nathan o
Marsh in this video we'll follow the
young whales Odyssey through the alien
ocean depths and discover a tale of loss
in deep connections and you can play the
full game yourself and support the
artist using the links below now the sea
is calling
the Journey of a lifetime begins in the
comforting warmth of an aquatic egg a
newborn mind is getting their very first
look at sunlight through the membrane of
their Sanctuary this is a male whale
calf not the sort of creature one might
expect to find incubating inside an egg
but this is no ordinary egg and this is
no ordinary calf and his extraordinary
life is about to start
a thunderous call reverberates from the
unknown World beyond the egg shaking the
calf to his core yet the calf isn't
frightened he recognizes the call as his
mother's instincts tell him to stretch
his new body for the first time pushing
against the membrane of the egg a scene
begins to open just one more impressive
stretch and the only World he's ever
known opens into a blinding light
warm tropical shallows flourish on the
other side of the egg to be completely
technical this is not an egg as we'd
understand it but a kind of external
womb that local scientists call a
birthing shell like most mammals on our
planet the whales we know give live
birth but we are no longer on our planet
at last the calf enters the teeming
Waters a bewildering array of Life
overwhelms his delicate senses tiny fish
waste no time in gobbling flecks of
nutrients foliage seems to react to our
calf's presence clinging to him like
they have a mind of their own even with
his mother's reassuring call this is all
too much for the calf he swims downward
passing bizarre sponges and Crustaceans
that dwell amidst the fronds something
gently puts a stop to his Panic dive or
calf is being carried to the surface the
upward motion is tender like the steady
movements of a cradle the young whale
has no idea what to take of any of this
at last he breaches and enjoys his first
critical breath of air like Earth whales
he can't breathe underwater and might
have drowned without intervention now
the calf finds himself in an empty
expanse in an ordinary season this
region would be filled with whales just
like himself instead the surface is
woefully empty with the unusual
exception of a large mass of plants or
calf stairs at the peculiar Island the
plant fronds continue to tenderly grasp
at him none of his instincts are any
help something moves Atop The heap of
plant matter
what is it
nothing good the infant decides the
surface world is much too strange diving
back under the surface the poor calf is
overwhelmed with fear and hunger he
knows he needs to nurse but can't locate
his mother the plants in snarum once
again as if detecting helplessness but
though only minutes old or calf is still
able to fight for survival biting the
vines his mother's comforting call makes
him stop the remarkable truth finally
Dawns on our calf the mass of foliage is
his mother and she has been with him all
along she is a Brillo whale at a
remarkable later stage of Life a window
into the calves astonishing future
[Music]
a suspicious pile of rock lies on the
Sandy floor of the Brillo breeding
grounds this warrants closer inspection
time for a deep scan
[Music]
just as we suspected it's a stone dog
this unique animal lives in a shell of
scavenge material much like the nomadic
hermit crabs of Earth speeches the stone
dog is trying to hide but is it a
convincing form of camouflage the
creature checks to make sure it hasn't
been spotted
too late or calf is looking for fun not
food but the stone dog doesn't know this
our calf has grown curious in
rambunctious his tumultuous birth hasn't
hindered his playfulness he enjoys
lifting his fluke into the air something
Earth whales do for a variety of reasons
including showing off
light rain has begun to fall a
phenomenon completely novel to the young
calf a Bellow from his mother reminds
him not to wander off though eager for
adventure the little calf is still much
too anxious to leave her side he
excitedly shows his mother what he has
found exploring by bumping it into her
face the mother is trying to rest but
her love for her son is stronger than
her weariness and this playing Is Not
Mere frivolity for cetaceans like whales
and dolphins play is a vital part of
cognitive development serving as
important training for catching food but
right now there's only one type of food
or whale calf cares about his mother's
milk will provide the nourishment needed
to grow a special layer of spongy tissue
that makes brilla whales so unique in
adult Brillo whales this tissue acts as
a refuge for other organisms allowing
for symbiosis beyond anything here on
Earth the mother is chosen to bond with
Botanical matter and while she might
appear overrun the truth is far more
interesting
another deep scan will reveal how plant
and animal life have merged to an
extraordinary degree unlike the stone
dog the foliage in small animals
surrounding the mother whale's body
aren't just camouflage but a way of life
like a kind of living Hotel her body has
designated areas where other life forms
can take up residence with a secondary
layer protecting her vitals from her
many house guests but this bizarre
Anatomy leaves us with more questions
than answers most notably what is the
benefit of such a peculiar system to
help us visualize the explanation we'll
get a Little Help From a sea bunny
better known as a sea bun the sea bun is
a mascot that has long been associated
with this planet however it is not a
real animal even in this world the
seabon myth originates from early days
of Planetary Exploration and with
something of an urban legend among the
first scientists over the years the joke
took on a light life of its own with
some people mistakingly believing the
sea bun to be an actual animal yet the
sea bun will serve as a helpful example
for why an organism might want to bond
with a whale underwater Locomotion is
energy intensive and carpooling with
another life form can be a great benefit
living on a huge whale also means
Predators might think twice about
getting close in return some animals
that partner with brillos will help them
hunt for food some Brillo Partners will
even feed directly off the whales
themselves in return for some sort of
useful service it might sound like too
strange a partnership to emerge but we
can find analika's relationships right
here on Earth Ox peckers are birds that
clean parasites off the side of large
mammals during the process the oxpecker
skims a marginal amount of the mammal's
blood as a sort of nutritional bonus the
large animals put up with this as the
parasite removal service is worth the
cost but brillos have taken symbiosis to
new extremes to the point where many
partner species have evolved
specifically to live their lives around
the whales sometimes the two life forms
become so interdependent they're
difficult to tell apart but such cases
are thankfully uncommon so what kind of
a relationship does the mother have with
her plants the answer has to do with
photosynthesis on her own the mother has
no way of extracting energy from the Sun
but plants do it all the time and they
share some of the sugars they produce
with their generous host the trade-off
is that she must spend a considerable
amount of time near the surface where
there's enough sunlight for the plants
to grow Emerald sea slugs of Earth have
a similar partnership with algae that
grows within their bodies however not
all passengers are welcome this is a
blood trilobite and they aren't here to
pay their fair share the blood trilobite
is a bandit pilfering from a vein with
an extended proboscis fortunately the
mother has a personal Bodyguard the
Vellum worm has one duty in this
ecosystem to remove uninvited guests
it's a busy job as herbivores also seek
to feed on her many leaves a Hungry Fish
thinks they've hit the jackpot they're
in for a rude awakening the Vellum worm
has a neurotoxin dispensing Barb to make
sure Gatekeepers get the message the
misfortunate fish stands little chance
the Brillo Wales ecosystem is called a
symbiotic Garden but like much of the
life on this planet these plants seem
too Earth-like to have evolved
independently just how did such species
come to this alien ocean that's a
question that we'll have to wait right
now our cathids discovered his mother's
plants are fun to play with but she
scolds him such behavior is currently
too risky for the mother is quite unwell
a sharp branch has punctured through her
protective layer these kinds of
complications can emerge in Brillo
whales as they get older the Thorns are
in danger of injuring her intestines a
sudden movement could mean the end the
mother does not know how long she will
be around to protect her calf and is
determined to reach the safety of the
Brillo herd before the situation worsens
to understand the voyage ahead let's
examine a simplified map of the
surrounding ocean the dark blue line
represents an ocean fault which pushed a
plan from the sea forming the chartreuse
archipelago the first human explorers
named each island in the chain including
South scrimshaw where this documentary
gets its title thus far the mother and
son have lived in the safety of the
nearby region of thalo bay but they have
traveled all the way to here and are
about to cross into dangerous open ocean
it is the dawn of a new day the mother
swims under the surface making
mysterious calls through the Deep the
calf returns from surfacing retreating
to the safety of the brambles beneath
his mother he doesn't understand the
purpose of her calls but he recognizes
she is on alert and that the waters
before them are deeper than any he's
known a sound comes from the far
distance
it's the call of another brilla whale
approaching their position or calf is
curious about the new arrival he spots a
far off spec and watches it grow
steadily larger even as the other whale
gets closer the calf seems uncertain
something about this other whale just
isn't right the calf Retreats further
into the Bramble Nest the mother
admonishes him in response as if
encouraging him to be more neighborly
his apprehension is understandable for
this Brillo whale is in a clever
disguise a false head is located on the
creature's tail an attempt at mimicking
a threatening Predator the Brillo has no
way to construct such a costume on its
own but this Brillo has a unique
symbiotic assistant a weaver lobe these
astute designers craft intimidating
attire for their Whale mobile homes to
deter attackers they spin the apparel
from a material called awesomer a unique
kind of long chain polymer while the
animal kingdom is full of clever
Architects it seems unlikely that a
single organism could create something
so complex instead it is likely that a
colony of Weaver lobes worked together
to craft the impressive camouflage in
any case this Brillo will be a powerful
Ally for the coming journey and she is
not alone like her mother she is looking
to transport her calf to safety or calf
still isn't feeling very welcoming and
he's in for another surprise visitor a
strange Rocky shape approaches from
behind it's another whale the armored
Brillo is also a mother and seems to be
suffering from an internal injury only
able to produce short honks while the
calf is uncomfortable these traveling
companions will make for a safer
Crossing his mother nudges him from
above it's time to depart
the deep ocean awaits
only 75 kilometers now separate the Pod
from the Great Southern Reef this final
stage of the voyage takes them over a
treacherous Abyssal trench so the
mothers swim in a defensive formation
with just three adults however they
cannot completely protect their calves
our youngster has done an admirable job
keeping up with the hurried Pace he too
can sense there is no time to linger
something is out there a dark shadow has
been following the Pod since the early
afternoon though it is yet to attack the
unknown pursuers seems to be biting its
time the calf no longer finds the other
brillos quite so frightening to his left
the Stony mother and her child swim in a
protective Arrangement this calf seems
just as uneasy as ours is the exterior
of the Stony mother has reduced in size
to become more streamlined shrinking via
some unknown internal mechanism
even when in exposed waters brillos are
full of surprises or calf doesn't
understand the Stoney mother's changed
appearance he turns his attention to
down below where the mimic mother swims
with her calf alongside a light from one
of the documentary Cruise drones since
this light has already interrupted the
shot this seems like a natural moment to
discuss the technology used in the
documentation of Brillo whales the
scientists who have come to this planet
primarily use repurposed drones in the
filming of wildlife the inner workings
of these drones are quite sophisticated
allowing them to keep Pace with Aquatic
Life without disturbing their natural
routines
returning to the scene the mimic mother
swims upside down to prevent attacks
From Below she's uneasy about a role in
the formation as her disguise isn't
effective from this angle or calf seems
concerned as well his mother reassures
him with a hum he is safe with her but
the shadow remains it's a penumbra shark
the fastest predator in this ocean it
could close the gap between itself and
the whales at any time there's no rush
like the Lightning Fast sailfish of
Earth's oceans the penumbra shark
possesses a mighty dorsal fin they keep
it withdrawn
until ready to strike in an instant the
shark has vanished in a panic the
mothers break from their defensive
formation or calf glances down and sees
nothing but open ocean he is completely
exposed to attack
instantaneously adrenaline floods his
system his brain goes into overdrive now
taking in every horrible detail the
monster's teeth shine like stoplights
through the darkness or calf cannot
possibly Escape in time but his mother
has a strategy tension resides in her
thorny branches that can be released
with whip-like speed one forceful snap
and her child is protected in a
fortification of branches but the shark
detects the shift and changes targets to
the stone mother's calf who is woefully
exposed or calf looks on in horror the
site is nearly too traumatic to process
it is only due to the vigilance of his
mother that our calf survived the
encounter
the safety of The Reef in the other
brillos are now very close the mimic
mother pulls the head of the Pod the
stone mother follows disoriented and in
shock after losing her only child or
calf is falling further and further
behind he does not wish to leave his
mother and she is not keeping Pace he
swims back to her trying to coax her to
continue but she is no longer moving
saving her calf came at the sacrifice of
reopening her pre-existing injuries
not understanding the calf calls to his
mother as he has a hundred times before
there is no response she is done all she
can to protect her son but can hold on
no longer
Steeler calf prods his mother to move at
this age our calf has no hope of
surviving alone without a mother's milk
or protection this could be the end
but another call Echoes across the water
the stone mother is circling back
a new day begins on the Great Southern
Reef the stone mother has arrived safely
and she is not alone our calf drinks its
fill of milk recovering from the arduous
Journey it is a moving case of social
adoption the stone mother's exterior has
now deflated to the point where we can
see she is a young adult quite small for
her species she has rescued her orphan
calf from certain doom and perhaps the
calf has rescued her as well physically
and emotionally exhausted the new family
gets a much needed rest in the morning
they will wake to an entirely new world
thank you
warm sunlight illuminates the coral of
the Great Reef an inquisitive bikini
fish picks Through The Irregular terrain
she's hungry and thinks she spotted
breakfast the minute eyes of greebles
peer out from the alcoves below the
bikili fish has her work cut out for her
trying to dig them out but before she
can begin she is rudely chased off a
large Hunter is throwing their weight
around this is a spotted Barnacle claw
and it will have no trouble catching
gripples a single forceful tug wrenches
the entire colony from the nooks below
the host Brillo whale isn't satisfied
with its partner species choice of food
it needs something a bit meatier our
young whale Witnesses the unfamiliar
spectacle from a distance even after
some time living on the reef there's
always something new to see the Bellows
of other brillos reverberate through the
water though many are strangers there is
at least one familiar face though her
appearance has changed considerably his
adoptive mother never Strays too far
away many eye spots now disguise her
exterior likely a response to the
penumbra shark attack and though he
might not look at or whale has changed
too his body has at last developed the
kind of necessary tissue layer to bond
with other species but what kind of an
adult will he become it's the most
important question in any Young brillo's
Life their nearly unlimited combinations
and the wrong choice can mean disaster a
common strategy is to imitate successful
adults a young Brillo finds a prosperous
grown-up and attempts to follow in their
footsteps adults will sometimes take
Apprentice brillos under their flippers
for multiple years providing them with
the materials needed to complete a
transformation not all body plans are
equally appealing this old veteran is
welcoming but our whale isn't sure it's
the career for him it's an
understandable feeling although another
low might be more open to the job offer
more than half of brillos choose to
replicate their biological mothers and
Orwell seems intent on preserving her
Legacy this Botanical mass is made of
the same plants his mother bonded with
but this Brillo has long passed and is
now nothing but an overgrown graveyard
though a whale cannot bond with the
decayed plants they still hold an
emotional significance or whale needs to
bond soon but is having trouble finding
a living plant-based Brillo there is one
exception an adult with a stunning cloak
of foliage but despite repeated attempts
from the youngster this adult doesn't
seem interested in taking on an
apprentice he is a lone male a bachelor
looking for a mate not a babysitting gig
his latest attempt to find love is a
dismal failure she seems confused by his
little Shadow who Yang said his
well-groomed coat it's the final straw
or whale bill is no longer welcome the
intricacy of brilla whale's symbiotic
Gardens is impressive but not entirely
unheard of a single adult human can have
over 39 trillion microbial cells inside
their body at a time not just germs
these foreign microorganisms play a
vital role in our survival the brillos
just take this concept further by
integrating with macro organisms there
are numerous species or whale could
merge with even if plants are off the
menu this reef is a never-ending
menagerie of life the reason for this
abundance has to do with the structure
of the coral itself the Great Southern
reef is a fringing reef comprised of
multiple layers Spire Coral is the
reason for the unique structure this
distinct species starts small then grows
steadily until it becomes a towering
mass that other corals grow on top of
within time the Central Mass is
smothered and the structure becomes over
and encumbered the tower then shatters
collapsing with new Spire Coral growing
from the Fallen giant this endless cycle
has created an environment of
innumerable Ravines in hideaways
organisms like saltwater tadpoles thrive
in this Coral City spending their early
stages safely hidden away before
emerging as mighty carnivores
well relatively Mighty Time Marches ever
onwards our young whale has seen many
forms of adulthood some of which are
completely baffling once again he isn't
interested one afternoon his fortune
seemed to turn when an impressive
Hunting Party reappears from the wild
the head of the Pod calls out to our
youngster he doesn't respond this adult
is a brilliant Huntsman partnering with
the chopper a rather unintelligent shark
species who sees him as a pack member
and follows his lead it's an incredible
strategy and this adult is ready to
share his tricks of the trade but our
whales still isn't moving all his
attention is on the chopper
his trauma is too severe to partner with
a shark species he flees over the coming
weeks or whale's mental health continues
to spiral it is crucial for his survival
that he starts symbiosis but he's too
unwell to begin the agitated youth can
sense that time is short but this stress
is little help
more adult brillos come and go this
camouflage whale is one of the more
unique that has appeared on the reef it
is covered in octopuses that have linked
themselves together allowing them to
instantly change their colors in unison
octopuses in our oceans have similar
color shifting abilities although they
pale in comparison to the color changing
abilities of their interplanetary
counterparts but the time has come at
last to answer the question of why life
on this planet seems so similar to life
on Earth one might assume the answer is
convergent evolution a process by which
different species evolve analogous
features due to comparable evolutionary
pressures but this answer is not
sufficient the true reason why brilla
whales look so much like Earth whales is
that they share a common ancestor
English scientist Francis Crick is
notable not just for helping to discover
the structure of DNA but for his theory
of directed panspermia this hypothesis
holds that life on Earth might have
sprung from seeds spread by an
interplanetary civilization while there
is little evidence such a thing happened
on Earth within this universe such an
idea was eventually put into practice on
newly discovered Earth-like worlds
numerous Barren planets were
intentionally seated with Earth's
species isolated across light years of
space these biospheres became home to
spectacular forms of New Life
this camo whale is a perfect example of
how strange life can get he hails or
wail as he swims past but the youth only
replies with fear the youngster is
reaching a point of crisis his innate
curiosity dulled he no longer finds joy
in the unknown even the dazzling
bioluminescence of Lamplighter fish
yields no reaction
but perhaps not All Is Lost another
youth has caught a Lamplighter and shows
it off to our whale and for once our
whale doesn't flee from the encounter
instead he seems excited to have made a
new acquaintance his sudden sociability
is unexpected but it might have to do
with the fact that young whales can't
pass partner organisms to their peers
whereas an adult could give him a
permanent symbiosis perhaps solar whale
really needed was a friend he could be
himself around the two whales spend the
rest of the day in each other's company
Night comes to the reef but our whale is
up past his usual bedtime he's out with
a pod of other adolescent brillos
they're here for a rare spectacle specks
of light from Lamplighter fish
illuminate the nearby Darkness this bold
mating display makes them easy to spot
but the lamplighters don't seem to care
about the young whales gobbling them up
it's an example of a strategy known as
Predator satiation where prey animals
Gather in such high numbers they know
there's a low chance of them being eaten
so they let the Predators have their
fill completely full and surrounded by
glowing lights or whale appears truly
happy to be spending a night with
friends
a new dawn seemingly the same as any
other but today the tide is particularly
low there are all sorts of interesting
things in the shallows if one isn't too
concerned about getting stuck
there's no more time for exploring
trying to escape the dropping water
level or whale becomes caught in the
current of the trenches one water slide
later and he is unceremoniously dumped
into uncharted waters he's now out past
the Great Reef a dangerous yet
intriguing Prospect and he's not alone
someone is watching from a nearby cave
it's a solitary Brillo whale or whale
swims closer although something seems
off this recluse has been exiled from
the herd banishment is rare in Brillo
culture and was likely the result of a
mating joust that turned deadly years of
painful isolation has made him truly
dangerous arbrillo says hello once more
still no response a hill made from a
shark's jaw indicates the hermit's
Fearsome might but his secret weapon
hides in a watchtower atop his armor
it's a vorepix octopus in its senses
death is on the menu he acts as the
Exile whales hunting partner normally
he'd assist in in staring prey but when
the target is as helpless as Orwell he
prefers to watch nothing like a front
row seat a strong emotion overpowers or
whale is it fear at last
evidently not instead of fleeing he's
playing and calling to the Exile as if
he's found a new friend but perhaps even
more remarkably the Exile isn't
attacking after Decades of loneliness
this sudden compassion seems to have
profoundly moved him he strains to
remember a Brillo song that isn't a
menacing warning it's not quite the show
the octopus was hoping to watch but he
seems to have an idea at over four
centuries old this cephalopod is highly
intelligent and knows a considerable
amount about Brillo biology swimming
closer he offers a Brillo a piece of the
Exile whales symbiotic armor plating one
swift motion and her whale's life is
changed forever
now that he is at last bonded with a
partner species over the coming years or
will change in remarkable ways
but for now the first phase of this
documentary is complete when we next
check in with our whale he might have
metamorphosized into something
unrecognizable but that won't be for
some time
that concludes all the chapters of South
scrimshaw release so far but Creator
Nathan omarsh is planning more entries
in the future in the meantime the full
game is free to play on Steam which I'd
highly recommend as The Full Experience
contains more World building details
than this video could cover there are
also links below to support the Creator
directly and follow him on social media
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video